from CNN Putin signs expanded anti-lgbtq
laws in Russia and latest Crackdown on
rights I was just about to say is that
what they're calling to know so the new
laws make it illegal to promote or
praise lgbtq relationships publicly
Express non-heterosexual orientations or
suggest that they are normal the package
of amendments signed by Putin include
heavier penalties for anyone promoting
non-traditional sexual relations and or
preferences as well as pedophilia and
gender transition under the new law it
will be banned across the internet media
books audio visual Services Cinema and
advertising so Ian was just asking why
the U.S is trying to go to war with
Russia well the U.S is very much in
favor of all of these things and Russia
opposes them well I think it's not just
like that I I think when we look at
examples like Saudi Arabia they commit
far more atrocious things than what
happens in Russia and they're far far
more as a bigger cultural difference
with Saudi Arabia than Russia I I think
it's even deeper than this there's
another article by Fox News that I think
is worth pulling up and it's titled Wall
Street CEOs funding China's military and
human rights abuses here's why and when
we look at the rise of China it is
partly responsible because of many
Western Elites the Rockefellers Henry
Kissinger uh and of course a lot of the
foreign policy that shipped American
jobs and labor overseas so there is an
effort to globalize the world but more
importantly control the world and in
China you see a lot of very powerful
billionaires in America financing that
movement you see Bill Gates you see
Klaus Schwab saying they're doing great
work when they're locking people inside
of their homes and there's fires there
there and literally people die because
of these fires now now when we when we
see that when we look at this coveted
zero policy these are policies that a
lot of people want to implement all over
the world so why is Russia at odds here
and China isn't well that should be
something that should have a lot of
people thinking what's really going on
here because it's not just cultural
differences I think there's a bigger
agenda trying to make China a perfect
example for the rest of the world I
think that's what they're going after I
think that's that's what they're trying
what's the situation with the Chinese
riots Revolution I mean it looks like
people all across the country were
stepping up and in crowds and like
overthrowing the government I mean it
looks like that's what they're
attempting to do what's going on there
that's what I was seeing uh I mean I saw
that Klaus Schwab said that the Chinese
model you know needed to be implemented
did everywhere else and then the Chinese
people themselves were pushing back
because yeah they're dying in these
fires they're still being
locked up by their government they have
their QR codes that dictate where they
can travel if they can leave or not
um so yeah as far as I'm concerned the
Chinese are still pushing back
um I'm not sure we all know that it's
very difficult to see what's actually
happening on the ground it's very hard
to verify all the news coming from there
because there's there there are some
reports saying that the Chinese
government is getting rid of
restrictions getting rid of some
lockdowns and allowing people to
quarantine inside of their own homes but
there's also more video footage of
police officers and these you know white
hooded crazy individuals busting down
doors and asking and demanding people's
cell phones so they could go through all
the data making sure that they didn't
they didn't share anything through
Bluetooth
um and and also airdrop yeah yeah
airdrop which uh you know Apple isn't a
big fan of and has stopped in China very
interestingly uh the same Apple that of
course makes very Grand statements about
George Floyd here domestically and makes
very big statements about Injustice here
domestically but doesn't seem to really
care about it when it's at their foxcom
Factory facilities that are up in arms
and revolting
well we want cheap stuff you know yeah I
want to work come on I wonder if you
could make it so when someone bought an
item they felt the pain and suffering of
every human that made the item and then
that will have to decide if they were
going to buy it or not doesn't it feel
that whenever there's an interesting
question about that though for some of
these people who uh this this is the way
it's often described when people are
positive towards like Sweatshop labor
they say these people live in
underdeveloped regions
are they better off
with no money per day starving or a
dollar per day working what do you think
I mean that's probably working see I
guess the issue is
it's none of our effing business it
would be better if an American worker
was getting 15 an hour to do that same
labor and they can figure out their own
issues you want to invest in the
development of that Nation by all means
go ahead and do so that sounds fantastic
sounds very nice of you to help these
people you know rise up become better
and and build better lives but why take
jobs and Industry from the United States
where American workers need these jobs
and then send them over to these
countries
because it's effectively slave labor
because they can sell the iPhone for 700
instead of 1900 what it would cost if we
built it over in the United States
probably if they built it here the
iPhone would still cost the same thing
their margins would be lower so they
built it over there ship it back here my
favorite story is how they make
skateboards they they cut down trees in
Canada send those trees to China where
they're turned into skateboards and then
sent to California to get put into
warehouses and distributed across the
U.S that's the stupidest thing I ever
heard but it's because it is cheaper to
burn all of that energy sending Lumber
to China than it is just to pay a North
American worker to do work
that's insane yeah that that's you look
when they talk about climate change and
all that stuff supporting the American
worker one of the best things you can do
to prevent climate change stop over
developing other nations how about that
you're concerned about carbon then stop
building factories or in in these
countries you want it you want to reduce
uh climate change stop running all the
fuel stop shipping Goods to China for
manufacturing just do it here yeah stop
planned obsolescence stop these products
being made in a way that they break down
within a year or two years so you have
to buy a new one again this larger kind
of consumerism this larger uh quasi
quasi-government policy that has been
instituted on everyone doesn't work in
anyone's favor and is essentially a
larger scam against everyone so this is
what we need to realize everything
everywhere we look it's a scam
how else can you how else can you answer
how else can you answer that question
you mean like capitalism is a scam no uh
saying the way that the system
nine the way that the system runs the
way that the system has been uh finagled
for the personal benefit of a lot of
these billionaires that do support China
that want China to be an example for the
rest of the world that right there is
rigged apple is supporting the Chinese
government the U.S government is now
dependent on the Chinese government on
those factories on everything being
shipped to the United States including
of course our medicine our vitamins our
supplements all the plastic all the
trinkets all of that is being made in
China right now and we are dependent on
it because we got rid of our own
industry we got rid of our own
infrastructure we took the jobs we took
the factories we had them here we had
the infrastructure to make things that
would actually last would actually be
good and we said no we're just going to
send them over to China to run this
larger Ponzi scheme on everyone and the
person who did it was David Rockefeller
and Henry Kissinger with their open
China policy Kissinger still is being
adored by Donald Trump adored by Joe
Biden adored by Obama Obama's National
Security adviser said that they took
their daily orders from Henry Kissinger
this guy's still calling the shots here
this is absolutely crazy and bewildering
that we're living in a society where
we're just being scammed every single
day how old is Kissinger he's still
around yes he's still around he's still
giving speeches I think he's 99. didn't
he not he's the architect of the Vietnam
War
I I don't know if you could call him the
architect but there was many human
rights violations that he committed in
Cambodia in in the south of Asia in
Chile and Latin America in the Middle
East uh I mean this guy is also the
figurehead of the petrol dollar I mean
this guy's behind almost every nook and
corner of secret society whether it's
the trilateral commission counts on
Foreign Relations or the Bilderberg
Group this guy's behind all these
organizations calling the shots
essentially telling people what to do
he's 99 by the way but but see when when
he passes is there anyone who can take
that mantle and and provide that same
advice or control there's probably a
whole bunch of other people that are
that are in secret his his underlings
Klaus Schwab was was working Kissinger
Juniors yeah yeah Clark Schwab was
working with Henry Kissinger very
closely as well they're very closely
associated Cloud Schwab was a student of
Kissinger
um so so that's another human being but
they're but the next person we're not
going to be hearing about the next
person is working in secret is working
in the shadows and they're implementing
policies they're probably setting the
policies right now that we don't even
know about I'm concerned they're not
American that they're like corporate
they're living they're globalists right
they don't they don't care about America
they never cared about America like they
never gave a damn about this country
they don't David Rockefeller bragged in
his own autobiography how he
specifically wanted to destroy American
sovereignty these are individuals that
openly brag I came up to David
Rockefeller I was like you said this in
your book how dare you he got mad and
then ran in his car but but at the end
of the day these people love to to brag
about how they're destroying this larger
experiment that in the first time in
almost all of recorded human history has
allowed individuals to have rights and
the ability to defend themselves that is
their Chief mortal enemy that they are
trying to get rid of at all costs they
want you uh to be fat they want you to
be sad they want you to be not be able
to defend yourself they want you to be a
slave and that's essentially the system
that they're building
yeah how else can you how else can you
say it's not being built I kind of think
they don't want you to exist at all yeah
you know it's it's like it's not that
they want you to die it's that they
don't want you to be alive I think
that's why we're going to see this big
push as well for right transhumanism and
neuralink because that's the next
natural step to this I feel like you
know the tick tock generation where
everyone is tied to their phones we have
this entire generation that is very
subservient because they're so tied to
their phone they're so distracted that
they're not paying attention to what's
actually happening in the modern day
which is why the government is so easily
able to come in and Usher in all of
these totalitarian Rule and whatnot
um the next natural progression to that
is transhumanism I know Libby Emmons was
talking about how you know you get the
chip implanted in your brain at that
point how do you know what is your your
own thought or a thought being
implemented via Ai and then at that
point are you just another like product
of Technology are you just another uh
what was the word that she used
um I can't remember off the top of my
head but essentially yeah everything's
just going to crap guys there there are
two shows that I recommend there's an
episode of Stargate sg1 where they go to
the so for you you know Stargate like
there's a portal they go through it they
find other plans and so in one they send
in this drone first and it's like a
wasteland but then all of a sudden
there's like a Flash and they're in this
beautiful looking city and what it is is
planet like had a pollution problem
everybody dies but there's this force
field surrounding the small town
everybody's networked to this machine
and there's like 1800 people who live
here what they eventually discover is
that initially the city had Millions but
the power is running out so the force
field is shrinking and people are dying
so to maintain the system people have to
be culled so the computer was wiping
their brains of memories of people who
were being sacrificed and they didn't
know so they meet a guy then like later
in the day they watch the guy walk out
to his death and they're like what was
that and they're like who are you
talking about that and that person never
lived here we've always been a small
City then there's an episode of our
Outer Limits where it's called the
stream or something where there are
these like Wi-Fi nodes everywhere and
everybody's like got a brain chip and
they don't realize that their thoughts
are implanted they think they're
individuals they think they're living
their normal life but they're acting at
the behest of the machine or whatever
and that's the danger of the brain chip
and I just kind of wanted to ask you
Savannah really quickly and then we
could go to You're echoing what I'm
thinking but I just want to ask you
specifically what do you think the end
game is what do you think is their goal
I think the end game is to create an
entire population that is subservient to
the government that is you know tied to
AI transhumanism where we're not
fighting back we're not pushing back why
is censorship so important right now
because we are highlighting that these
issues are prevalent and that they're
happening
um but the government wants to come in
and they want everybody to be distracted
one of the things that I focus in on and
I've been thinking about this a lot
because there's a part of me that thinks
sometimes that what I do is useless
because I can sit here all day long and
scream to high heaven about what is
happening in society but it really is up
to the masses to actually act on it
right so what is the the true solution
to this and the true solution is
traditional family and instilling that
because for example the New York Post
just put out this article that talked
about these parents having to send their
kids to counseling because of all of the
drug abuse that's happening and these
kids are being exposed to it it's
horrifying them these parents are the
ones that are thinking of moving out of
the big cities crime rates and drug use
are affecting these people specifically
because as they have a family and that's
at the Forefront from them that's why in
our society today we're trying to
destroy Traditional Values to destroy
traditional family because then the
average person doesn't really care about
what's going on then the average person
is just tied to their cell phone they
don't really care okay they live in the
Pod they'll watch porn all day uh you
know they're I guess living off of the
whatever app that they're they're living
through so I'm like completely
butchering this but the point that I'm
trying to make here is I feel like the
ultimate end game is to have an entire
population that's not going to push back
against a One World Government
yeah that very much scares me about
implanting memory I think you're right
really onto something with that because
memory itself is flawed no human is
Perfect Memory I think the things I
think may or may not have been what
really happened sometimes I'm just wrong
I'll say it and I'll go back and I'll
review the tape and I'll be like oh what
I remembered was different than what
happened I can only imagine that I mean
with TV and radio like that's already
manipulating our thoughts and memories
I think you're I think you might be onto
it like a muted or docile populace is
helpful for a government uh in some ways
so that the government the populace
doesn't overtake the government thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time